willkommen liebe zuschauer bei history
live den historischen quartett auf
phoenix jesus mythos und wahrheit
darüber diskutieren wir heute mit der
theologin annette märz und den theologen
klaus renz und hermann detering drei
theologen und ein thema der geschichte
denn uns interessiert die frage wer war
jesus und was weiß die wissenschaft
darüber
rommerz sie sind die co autorin eines
buches mit dem titel der historische
jesus was ist ihr fazit wer war jesus
eine ganze menge über jesus nicht wissen
aber einiges doch auch finde ich relativ
sicher wissen
es war ein jüdischer lehrer jesus war
ein wundertäter jesus war ein endzeit
prophet
er war schüler johannes des täufers
denke ich wir wissen ziemlich sicher
dass er unter pontius oder wir wissen
sicher dass er unter pontius pilatus
gekreuzigt wurde das heißt wir können in
historisch einordnen in die zeit seinen
tod in die zeit zwischen 26 und 36 nach
christus
und ja die quellenlage bringt es mit
sich dass über den inhalt der
verkündigung jesu eine ganze menge
diskussion herrscht wenn man historisch
nach jesus fragt wird man immer auch nur
wahrscheinlichkeit urteile fällen können
über solche fragen
doch denke ich dass man auf einem ganz
auf einer ganzen reihe gebieten doch
auch relativ wahrscheinliche aussagen
noch machen kann
da wird vielleicht in der nächsten
stunde gelegenheit zu sein über soll es
durch stichwort quellenlage herr dr -ing
sie haben sich ja auch mit den quellen
von frau märz beschäftigt sind diese
quellen stichhaltig entschuldigen sie
frau merk ich finde die quellen die sie
zitieren ihrem buch nicht stichhaltig
insofern als sie die existenz eines
historischen jesus in meinen augen
jedenfalls nicht beweisen
sie führen auch die evangelien an
aber die evangelien sind natürlich in
erster linie glaubenszeugnis das ist
ganz klar und glaubenszeugnisse in dem
sinne dass sie also auch eine bestimmte
tendenz der verfasser jeweils erkennen
lassen
insofern sind also die evangelien hier
sehr mit vorsicht zu genießen anders
verhält es sich natürlich jetzt mit
paulus paulus ist ja ein fast ein
zeitgenosse jesu und als zeitgenosse
könnte man ja erwarten dass ja auch
historisch die meisten informationen
über jesus präsentiert seine briefe wenn
sie denn echt sind sind um die mitte des
ersten jahrhunderts entstanden und diese
erwartung wird aber leider getäuscht
denn paulus spricht nicht vom
historischen jesus sondern sein jesus
ist protagonist in einem mythologischen
in einem kosmischen drama und auch
pontius pilatus taucht hier nicht auf
sondern stattdessen ist von den archos 2
1 aus tutow also von den herrschern der
welt zeit die rede
mit anderen worten was ich damit sagen
will paulus versetzt sein hinten jesus
in ein mythologisches drama das ja nur
schwer wiegen der vorwurf frau
märz sind ihre quellen denn dann
gefälscht oder nur mit logisch unsere
quellen sind glaubenszeugnisse da gebe
ich an den ring absolut recht
aber sie erzählen von einer historischen
gestalt und von einer gestalt die nur
vergleichsweise kurze zeit
in der vergangenheit gelebt hat wenn wir
vielleicht gehe ich erstmal direkt
aufbau dass ein paulus spricht von den
brüdern jesu und deren frauen die die
jesus verkünden
er hat selber den historischen jesus
nicht gekannt und den irdischen jesus
nicht gekannt von daher hat er ein wählt
er einen anderen ausgangspunkt im
übrigen zitiert er auch ganz vereinzelt
durchaus jesus traditionen manchmal mit
und manchmal ohne namensnennung aber
ganz viele traditionen der bergpredigt
finden wenn paulus briefen zurück dass
ehescheidung slogan jesu finden wir
zurück wenn wir in den in den paulus
briefen aber die evangelien sind ja
unabhängig voneinander entstandene
quellen mit sehr vielen widersprüchen
die trotzdem an einigen punkten
konvergieren und insofern haben wir
denke ich historisch ist es viel
wahrscheinlicher aber es geht immer um
wahrscheinlichkeit sie haben gesagt ich
kann es nicht beweisen
beweisen kann ich nicht nicht mit 100
prozentiger sicherheit aber die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass aus der vielzahl
der verschiedenen quellen die über jesus
uns etwas erzählen aus dem ersten und
frühen zweiten jahrhundert zu schließen
ist dass er als historische gestalt
gelebt hat diese wahrscheinlichkeit ist
um viele viele viele maße maßen höher
als die wahrscheinlichkeit dass es sich
um ein mythologisches lesen handelt das
sekundär innerhalb von wenigen
jahrzehnten mythologie siert worden wäre
das ist so unwahrscheinlich dass ich es
wirklich nicht reden wir jetzt mal über
die familien erwächst entwickelt sich
eine stich lassen
sind diese evangelien eine stichhaltige
quelle wenn es darum geht etwas über
jesus erfahren wenn sie vielleicht die
stichhaltige quelle also in meinen augen
sind die evangelien die einzig relevante
quelle über jesus dass sie sich auf
einen menschen beziehen einen jüdischen
menschen der zu bestimmter zeit mit
bestimmten schicksal mit dem tod am
kreuz unter dem präfekten pontius
pilatus erlebt und gestorben ist dass
sie sich darauf beziehen leitet gar
keinen zweifel sie selber lassen das als
ganz selbstverständlich erkennen dass
sie sich auf eine konkrete geschichte
beziehen
selbstverständlich sind sie
glaubenszeugnisse und die frage wäre
dann wie viel das ist dann der streit
mit frau merz aber an dem punkt dass das
habe ich mir überhaupt keinen streit die
frage ist dann wie viel man an
historisch genau und zuverlässigen im
einzelnen über was würden sie sagen wie
viel daran ist mythos wie viel wahrheit
wie viel ich glaube ich würde es
gerichtet ich würde die frage nicht
alternativ stellen zwischen mythos und
wahrheit sondern würde dann die frage
der wahrheit im mythos auch stellen
die frage ist doch was wir jetzt als
wirklich ansehen ob wirklich nur das
wirklich ist was sich als historische
faktizität erweisen lässt oder ob es
nicht auch eine andere ebene von
wirklichkeit gibt dass es jedenfalls die
auf die die evangelien aus sind die
evangelien haben in ihrem erzählen teil
am biblischen reden biblischen erzählen
als ein erzählen von konkreter
geschichte die aber mit gott zusammen
gedacht wird das ist ihr interesse des
biblischen erzählens und auch des
erzählens der evangelien die haben nicht
das interesse protokollarisch
zutreffenden auskünfte über den menschen
jesus zu geben sondern sie stellen diese
geschichte da in der dimension gottes
und diese dimension können sie nur
deutlich machen indem sie legende arisch
erzählen
gut dennoch interessiert uns ja der
historische jesus der in den evangelien
aufscheint gelder doch mal durch
matthäus markus lukas und johannes wer
von den vieren bildet den den
historischen jesus ihrer ansicht nach am
besten ab erzählt er in keiner
das hängt auch damit zusammen dass für
mich die evangelien keine
augenzeugenberichte sind das die
evangelien auch sehr spät entstanden
sind wenn wir noch untestierte zuschauer
wie viel später genannten sind also wenn
jesus um 30 gestorben und auferstanden
ist dann sind sie also am ende des
ersten jahrhunderts entstanden
das problem ist dabei natürlich auch
dass die evangelien möglicherweise sogar
noch später entstanden sind denn als
indiz dafür dass die evangelien am ende
des ersten jahrhunderts entstanden sind
benutzen wir im allgemeinen zwei
leuchttürme ignatius ignatius briefe und
den ersten clemens brief und ob diese
schriften tatsächlich echt sind
es ist immer noch sehr umstritten mein
lehrer walter schmidt saß beispielsweise
hatten
ignatius briefe sämtlich für unecht
gehalten und auch der erste clemens
brief steht im verdacht in echt zu sein
das bedeutet mit anderen worten das also
theoretisch ist auch möglich ist die
evangelien entstehung in das zweite
jahrhundert zu setzen
irenäus von lyon ist der erste der einen
vier evangelien kann und kennt das muss
man einfach mal festhalten und was davor
war das ist mehr oder weniger alles
spekulation und nur noch soviel jetzt zu
den evangelien namen matthäus markus
lukas und johannes da weiß man ja auch
dass diese namen erst später hinzugefügt
wurden möglicherweise auf irgendwelche
anonymen schriften denn man hatte auf
diese weise versucht die schriften also
die evangelien in
die apostolische zeit praktisch zu
transportieren aus diesem und daraus
augenzeugenberichte zu machen indem man
sie in dem man sie also fälschlich unter
dem namen dieser apostel bezeichnete ja
da ist eine menge zweifel fairbanks was
die evangelien betrifft
wie wurden sie geschrieben wann wurden
sie geschrieben vor allen dingen warum
und sind es fälschung ist weil die frage
was man unter fälschung versteht also
wenn fälschung meinen sollte dass man
würde wenn als kriterium ist das
protokollarisch exakt berichtet wird was
tatsächlich geschehen ist
dann stimmen die evangelien einfach
nicht überein dass aber auch nicht ihr
bier
die haben eine ganz anderes interesse
die verfasser
ich denke von der zeitlichen ansetzung
her braucht da braucht man nicht die
kleben den ersten lebens brief und die
ignatius briefe das sind hilfs argumente
sondern aus der aus den evangelien
selbst was sie an zusagen
zeitgeschichtlichen kolorit erkennen
lassen
denke ich lassen sich alle vier
evangelien in die zeit zwischen 70 und
100 also 70 als das jahr der tempel
zerstörung und 100 das ist nicht ganz so
sicher aber da wir ja auch handschriften
funde haben die relativ alt sind die
schon das schema haben was dann auch die
späteren auch handschriften zweiten
dritten jahrhundert haben die er die den
selben technik der abkürzungen das
spricht dafür dass man wirklich 100 grob
gesagt als terminus angeht zwischen
frage eines wissen wollen den unkundigen
wenn sie um 100 entstanden sind kirchen
70 und mutig aber kann das dann
überhaupt aus biologischen gründen einer
der jünger jesu
das vertritt auch keinen dass das leute
sind die aus der zweiten oder dritten
generation sind die sich aber auf
tradition beziehen und die nicht den
leisesten zweifel bekunden dass der
mensch über den sie schreiben nicht
fiat hätte dass das reine mythologie
wäre also von daher noch mal ist ihr
interesse und das macht sie eigentlich
auch spannend alle vier und da möchte
ich fragen welches evangelium ist näher
an der historischen wahrheit sondern
jedes evangelium hat sein eigenes profil
weil sie eben diesen jesus nicht als
einmal gewesen und leider tragisch
umgekommenen darstellen sondern weil sie
aufgrund des auferstehungsglauben sie
ihn als einen lebendig gegenwärtigen in
ihrer gemeinden reinschreiben und damit
auch erfahrungen ihrer eigenen zeit mit
in die historische darstellung
reinbringen und darum finde ich viel
spannender als die rückfrage nach einem
historischen jesus die auch die
historische rückfrage nach den
evangelien in ihrer unterschiedlichen
profilierung
das können wir gerne mit aufnehmen aber
zunächst doch mal wenn wir uns mit den
evangelien beschäftigen das wollen die
menschen ja wissen
die inhalte der evangelium ist jetzt
einfach mal die wunder die nach den
evangelien jesus vollbrachter tat oder
vollbracht haben soll
ich nenne jetzt mal stichwort übers
wasser laufen aus wasser wein machen
kranke heilen legende oder wahrheit
man muss doch wirklich differenzieren
dass jesus ein wunderheiler gewesen ist
der weithin in palästina dafür berühmt
war dass er kranke heilen konnte und
dämonen austrieb und das sind zwei
unterschiedliche kategorien auch kranke
und dämonisch besetzen dafür haben wir
viele zeugnisse und sogar auch aus
biblischer die wenigen notizen die wada
haben nehmen darauf bezug kranken
heilungen und dämonen austreiben kann
man ganz sicher dem historischen jesus
zu schreiben damit steht er im übrigen
auch in einer reihe mit anderen
jüdischen exorzisten des ersten
jahrhunderts das ist also etwas das wir
kulturgeschichtlich auch verordnen
können wo es auch vergleichsmaterial
gibt das ist für historiker immer
wichtig dass man auch analogien
hat mit den sogenannten naturwundern ist
es eine andere sache er ist sicher nicht
übers wasser gelaufen das wird ein
historiker jedenfalls als historische
aussage verifizierbare empirischen
reduzierbare aussage nicht konkurrieren
können
da muss man sich fragen was steckt
dahinter
eine möglichkeit ist es steckt dahinter
die überzeugung dass jesus göttlich ist
gott dass es eines der attribute die
gott gegenüber menschen hat ist dass er
über das meer schreitet über das meer
gebietet schon im alten testament andere
interpretation die man gegeben hat sind
oster erscheinungen die hier verarbeitet
sind auf dem wasser wir wissen das nicht
es wird in diesem medium einer solchen
wunder geschichte etwas ausgesagt über
den glauben an jesus aber das
entscheidende ist dass man durch
vergleich der der quellen und eben auch
sie in ihrem historischen kontext zu
verorten begründete aussagen darüber
machen können dass jesus wunderheiler
gewesen ist was jetzt noch interessant
ist um ihn zu unterscheiden von anderen
wunderheilern aus dem ersten jahrhundert
ist welche bedeutung hat er den wundern
gegeben
und da ist ganz entscheidend nach einem
relativen konsens der historischen jesus
forschung dass er sie als zeichen der
anbrechenden gottes herrschaft gedeutet
hat gesagt wenn ich mit dem finger
gottes die dämonen austreiben dann ist
das reich gottes bei euch angekommen
es ist wahrscheinlich für jesus
selbstverständnis und für sein
verständnis von der gottes herrschaft
sehr entscheidend gewesen dass da ganz
realistisch weil beschauen menschen
gesund wurden
und vielleicht so viel was wir ja in
allen vier evangelien finden ist ja das
stichwort auferstehung jesu auferstehung
jesu ist das nur theologie
was ist daran in der entstehung dieser
schriften in sachen ausstellung als
daran geschichte
frage ich sie alle dann habe ich jetzt
vielleicht gelegenheit nochmal meinen
ansatz an dieser stelle ein bisschen zu
erklären also gerade stehen auferstehung
betrifft ja wir wissen ja obwohl das
eine zeit lang auch bestritten wurde
dass es in der antike sterben und
auferstehen de gott halten im umfeld des
antiken christentums gegeben hat des
adonis ihres oder wie sie alle heißen
alle waren da noch auf ihre weise hatten
auf ihre weise ein ähnliches schicksal
im kern die der jesus der evangelien und
im übrigen auch waren diese auferstehung
feiern und klare tage in der artikel
über das ganz im ganzen mittelmeerraum
verbreitet
und ich meine dass tatsächlich das
christentum das frühe christentum
angeknüpft hat diese sterbenden
auferstehen den gottheiten und daraus
einen ganz eigenen mythos geformt hat in
kombination mit dem gymnastischen mythos
vom zum himmel
vom himmel kommen und zum himmel
steigenden erlösen und dieser ganz
eigenen mythos denn das christentum hier
gebildet hat war zunächst noch ohne
zeitliche fixierung ja da ist dann
später in späterer zeit die
historisierung dazugekommen die
historisierung hat hier eingesetzt und
hat dann diesen mythos auch in einem
geschichtliches faktum verwandelt der
antike mythos hat eben halt immer diese
schwerkraft das kann man auch bei moss
ihres mieters beobachten
auch da gesellt sich dann an den rändern
historische das mit hinzu er hat diese
schwerkraft historisch zu werden und das
ist hier christliche das auch geschehen
ich wollte mit anderen worten eigentlich
auch nur eines sagen dass es durchaus
möglich ist eine plausible erklärung der
entstehung des christentums auf dieser
mythologischen grundlage zu geben dass
wir nicht zwingend davon ausgehen müssen
dass also der kern der historische jesus
gewesen ist er dann eben mit
verschiedenen christo logischen plakaten
behängt wurde und dann theologe zahn bis
ausgedrückt hat der zweiten person in
baltimore gejubelt wurde sondern es gibt
eine andere möglichkeit zur erklärung
dieses phänomens war die auferstehung
jesu also eine bewusst von den aposteln
den verfassern formulierter mythos nein
also ich glaube von dem kein wort was
der niedrigen eben gesagt hat das neue
testament ist so eng mit dem alten
testament zu verbunden also der
jüdischen bibel sich einfach
anachronismus sind für neutestamentliche
zeit von neuen testament und alten
testament spricht das ist meine
lernerfahrung der letzten 20 30 jahren
dass die meisten schriften des neuen
testaments jedenfalls alle die die im
ersten jahrhundert geschrieben worden
sind von haus aus gar keine christlichen
schriften sind sondern im haus aus
jüdische schriften weil sie im ersten
jahr und oder gar kein christentum gab
was sich als solches jahren jesus war
jude und seine anhänger waren auch
jüdinnen und juden und die verfasser des
am meisten schriften des neuen
testaments jedenfalls der im ersten
jahrhundert waren
entweder juden oder eben vielleicht der
lukas in gänsefüßchen mich sowas als
dritter evangeliums nennen
der war vielleicht ein nicht jude aber
einer der jüdisch zu sagen gelernt hatte
einer von den sogenannten gottes
verehrenden die auch durch inschriften
in der antike
da sind und da ist ein so enger
zusammenhang
das essen die schriften des neuen
testaments basieren ganz und gar auf der
jüdischen bibel haben sie als ihren
sprachraum mit dem sie sprechen und von
daher muss man auch für die auferstehung
nicht irgendwelche mythen herbeiziehen
sondern kann das viel plausibler aus der
jüdischen tradition her verstehen von
dem analogen schicksal der magischen
märtyrern die zweite makkabäer 7
beschrieben werden wo sich dann die die
hoffnung ausgedrückt wird dass die die
hier brutal umgebracht werden von gott
auf erweckt werden wo auch deutlich ist
dass die frage der auferweckung nicht
von daher kommt weil man gerne ewig
leben möchte sondern weil es um die
frage der gerechtigkeit geht dazu zu
sagen ob noch was gutzumachen an deren
schicksal und das schicksal jesu ist da
ganz analog und da haben dann die zeugen
durch was immer veranlasst paulus als
einer der das als eigenes erleben
beschreibt deutet das immer nur kurz an
eine erscheinung dass er was erfahren
hat dem setzten sozusagen noch eins
drauf indem sie nicht die aussage machen
gott wird ihn auferlegen sondern gott
hat ihn auferweckt und das halte ich für
den grundsatz des neuen testaments von
dem aus die schriften im ganzen bestimmt
sind und das nicht dass der liebe gott
an einmal gezeigt dass er sowas machen
kann einen boden lebendig sondern als
anfang neuer schöpfung und das war es
dann auch was diese verkündigung
attraktiv gemacht hat weil offenbar in
dieser gemeinschaft schon was von neuer
schöpfung erfahren worden ist in
grenzüberschreitenden verhalten mit
einer
also eine von menschen beschriebene
gemacht der hoffnung vielleicht
antworten angegriffen worden ja ja ich
meine wenn sie mit solcher sicherheit
jesus im judentum verorten würde sonst
ja nun gut man schön es gibt auch andere
möglichkeiten das wissen sie ja auch auf
den bergpredigt die kann ja auch ganz
anders gedeutet werden als sie das
machen also verstoß klinischen
hintergrund beispielsweise ja da gibt es
ja auch alternativen die sind in amerika
etwas verbreiteter als hier bei uns aber
die gibt es und das hat ja auch lange
seine tradition gehabt nur was ich jetzt
sagen wollte wenn man jetzt jesus somit
solcher sicherheit im judentum verordnet
ich rate doch wirklich dazu erst einmal
zu prüfen ob er denn überhaupt hier in
unserer menschlichen geschichte
verordnet werden kann
denn blicken wir doch mal auf die
evangelien die lassen durchaus zweifel
daran jedenfalls für uns modernen
menschen
die evangelien beginnen mit der nicht
das markus-evangelium aber matthäus und
lukas mit der jungfrauengeburt jesus
wandelt auf dem wasser er heilt er hat
die finanzwerte fähigkeit wasser in wein
zu verwandeln
und er wird in den himmel aufgehoben um
hieraus einen menschen zu machen muss
man doch erst einmal all diese dinge
abziehen
ja das ist daneben die berühmte
subtraktion methode wäre sich die
geologen bedienen ja doch dass es sich
ausgehen dass muss ich eben zu ende
dennoch die subtraktion methode alles
was irgendwie mythisch was irgendwie
übersinnlich was ich weiß nicht was ist
das wird abgezogen um auf diese weise
zum menschen jesus zu gelangen und das
ist in meinen augen das muss ich einfach
sagen die reinste willkür in ähnlicher
form könnte beispielsweise auch ein
märchen forscher sagen das märchen
rotkäppchen ist historisch wir nehmen
jetzt noch einmal hier die
entsprechenden wolf recht wir nehmen die
sache mit der großmutter im bauch das
wollte und das mädchen mit den roten
sammelt käppchen allerdings das ist
historisch nicht alles meine zukunft
mache ich überhaupt nicht sondern die
evangelisten setzen ganz
selbstverständlich voraus dass es sich
um diesen menschen handelt aber sie
wollen ihn von vornherein in der
dimension gottes darstellen sie wollen
deutlich machen dass in reden handeln
und erleiden dieses menschen kein
geringerer als bot selbst wie in der
jüdischen bibel bezeugt wird zum zuge
kommt und dazu kommen dann all das was
sie meinen was man abziehen müsste wenn
man historisch fragt uns durch fragt
muss man abziehen
ich frag nicht in dieser weise
historisch nicht nehme die
voraussetzungen der evangelien ernst
dass es um diesen menschen geht den sie
eben mit ihrer darstellung in die
dimension gottes stellen wollen weil sie
glauben zeugnisse sind frau können sie
in diesem streit vermitteln oder wollen
sie das überhaupt ein kleines bisschen
was die mythologischen elemente angeht
da denke ich kann man durchaus abzielen
subtrahieren das muss man auch wenn man
die geschichte alexanders des großen
schreiben möchte der nämlich auch von
apollo gezeugt wurde und das berichten
zwei ton und andere ernstzunehmende
historiker das heißt man muss die jesus
überlieferung wirklich als das nehmen
was sie ist natürlich wir haben
evangelien die einheiten sind aber in
denen sind sie sagten das schon ältere
traditionen verarbeitet und bei diesen
traditionen muss man muss man einfach
differenzieren die kindheitsgeschichte
und die geburtsgeschichte liegen auf
einmal ganz anderen ebene wie bei
alexander dem großen
auf einer ganz anderen ebene als zum
beispiel die überlieferung von jesu
leere
wie kommt das als jesus lehrte waren
seine jüngerinnen und jünger dabei die
haben das auch über den oster graben
hinaus dieselbe verkündigung fortgesetzt
das heißt sie wussten was sie sagten und
da finden wir dann auch im kern viel
mehr
quellenmaterial dass wir kritisch
vergleichen können und wo wir versuchen
können zu einsatz noch zu konsens wegen
aussagen zu kommen
bei der geburt war von den späteren
anhängerinnen und anhänger niemand dabei
da hat man also ein wissens vakuum
aufzufüllen
zwischen frage was unser einem so
auffällt wenn er sich damit beschäftigt
dass jesus ans kreuz genagelt worden ist
diesen passus finde ich ja nur bei
johannes bei den anderen evangelien
nicht die erwähnen solche nägel mit
keinem wort hatte johannes mehr
informationen
naja hat vielleicht einfach nur
drastischer abbilden wollen was man
wusste wie römische kreuzigung
passierten
man hat in palästina einen gekreuzigten
aus dem ersten jahrhundert gefunden hat
in so genannten gekreuzigt mich darauf
so oder so da hat man den nagel noch in
den knochen
wir können davon ausgehen würde ich mich
drauf verwetten ob das in diesem fall
passiert ist wissen wirklich können wir
das nicht aber sehr oft kann uns
tatsächlich zeit historisches wissen
helfen lücken die die quellen uns
niemals
erklären werden doch imaginieren tan zu
füllen und ich weiß dass sie enorm
polemisieren gegen das imaginieren aber
ich denke dass historikerinnen und
historiker oft nicht anders können und
dann doch zu
auch nicht anders dürfen und dann doch
zu relativ plausiblen und mehrlich aber
doch relativ plausiblen aussagen kommen
insofern würde ich sagen
johannes hat es vielleicht nicht mal
gewusst aber er wusste und wollte
deutlicher einfach aufschreiben was
geschah nun hat ja auch papst benedikt
in seiner eigenschaft als theologe alle
evangelien untersucht die unterschiede
weggelassen und einen harmonischen jesus
gefunden zitat joseph ratzinger eine
historisch sinnvolle und stimmige figur
kann man dem zustimmen erwächst also in
meiner perspektive hat der papst papst
hier ein blick auf die historische jesus
frage einen trick für macht er hat alle
evangelien harmonisieren zusammen
gelesen und behauptet das wären
der historische jesus und damit die
widersprüche die in den quellen da sind
die eben eine ganz andere intention
haben glatt gebügelt in meinen augen
lichter im selben spital krank wie die
übrigen historischen jesus forscher das
ist mir deutlich geworden an dem was er
seinen konstruktions punkt nennt er sagt
ausdrücklich sein konstruktions punkt
ist ein behauptet eine behauptete
besonders enge intime beziehungen
zwischen den menschen jesus und gott und
das ist nicht der konstruktions punkt
der evangelien die evangelien haben
einen anderen konstruktions punkt die
haben ihren ansatz beim glauben dass
gott diesen hingerichteten von den toten
auferweckt hat und von daher stellen sie
seine geschichte je unterschiedlich dar
und jede historische jesus suche auch
die des papstes
geht hinter diesen konstruktions punkt
der evangelien notwendig zurück und
hintergeht damit theologisch das was
grundsatz der familien ist das
hintergehen etwas sagen weil das auch so
ein wort das ist so negativ als ob man
den evangelien nicht gerecht würde wenn
man sie auch historisch gefragt und ich
finde ich bin die erste die evangelien
auch theologisch lesen möchte und auch
darüber predigen möchte aber man
hintergeht ein historiker der in einer
bestimmten zeit geschrieben wurde man
hintergeht ihn nicht wenn man ihn auch
befragt auf das was er an rückschlüssen
ermöglicht auf die zeit in der er
geschrieben ist und auf die person über
die er geschrieben ist meiner meinung
nach okay aber dann sollte man wissen
was die evangelien als historische
quellen leisten vielleicht gemacht hat
darüber ein stück streiten
david friedrich strauß der 18 35 in
seinem ersten leben jesu in den späteren
es nicht mehr so gut gemacht da ist er
rückfällig geworden aufgrund
biografischen erfahrungen hat er seinen
ersten leben jesu wirklich eine
durchgehende evangelien kritik durch
historische frage rein historische
fragestellungen durchgeführt und hat
dann als einigermaßen wahrscheinlich
oder auch hoch wahrscheinlich dass durch
historische gerüste des lebens jesu
gefunden was ungefähr dem entsprach was
sie auf die erste frage von der knop
geantwortet haben finde ich voll okay
dass das kann man wirklich mit gutem
gewissen sagen was man daraus gefunden
hat vielleicht auch das eine oder andere
aber so wie sie weiter fragen finden
finden sie sich doch in einem irren
streit von meinungen und eine
wahnsinnigen vielfalt
unterschiedlichster jesus bilder der
spitze ich noch mal zu und sage der
historische jesus wir von der
wissenschaft heraus gefunden wird ist
ein wechselbalg darüber wollen wir jetzt
mal reden aber vorher hätte ich gern
auch mal ein dating gehört als
zwischenfazit wenn der jesus aus den
evangelien zu verstehe ich sie blank am
mythos es keine handfeste historische
figur ist dann auch das frühe
christentum auf einem
ein mythos beharren und nicht auf einer
nachvollziehbaren wirklichkeit ja sicher
warum auch nicht
also es hat sich ja schon sagte antike
mysterien kultige geben
ich habe den diskurs zum beispiel auch
erwähnt in rom
da gab es in diesem diskurs klage feiern
und auferstehung feiern die sogenannten
deal arien und diese feiern die fangen
interessanterweise auch zur frühjahrs
nacht und tag gleiche stadt also zu eben
derzeit in der dann später die christen
ostern und karfreitag feierten
und ich meine das sind doch alles
bezugspunkte die kann man nicht einfach
so außer acht lassen
da muss man doch auch mal ein bisschen
drüber nachdenken und das vermisse ich
allerdings hier bei den theologen doch
sehr ich fühle mich da inzwischen auch
hier natürlich ein bisschen in der
minderheit
dass dieser standpunkt überhaupt geprüft
wird dieser mythologische standpunkt ich
meine es gibt ja im grunde eigentlich
nur zwei oder drei um das phänomen jesus
zu erklären gibt es drei möglichkeiten
einmal den polizisten ansatz da brauchen
wir jetzt gar nicht weiter drüber zu
reden
da ist also die die sind die evangelien
wiedergabe eines historischen geschehens
dann gibt es ihren ansatz
das ist der es hat einen kern gegeben
ein zimmermann zonen aus nazareth der
noch malzahn hochgejubelt wurde zur
zweiten personen der gotthard aber auch
noch den dritten ansatz und den möchte
ich doch einfach nur noch mal wieder ins
gespräch werden
dann möchte ich auch das einfach mal
chirurgen sich damit stärker
auseinandersetzen dass am anfang ein
mythos war und dieser mythos
historisiert wurde
warum wird dieser ansatz in den
theologischen diskussionen nicht berührt
das kann ich ihnen ganz genau sagen weil
es hier anders weil es an das
eingemachte geht weil es letztlich darum
geht das hier theologische grundfesten
dadurch erschüttert würden durch das
fazit einen historischen jesus hat es
nicht gegeben so stichwort wechselbalg
jetzt reden wir mal über die
nichtchristlichen quellen in sachen
jesus die römischen und jüdischen
quellen und andere quellen was sagen die
uns den vom erz was scheint da auf die
sind sehr knapp und sie bestätigen im
grunde die basis fakten
ich bin überhaupt nicht der meinung wir
dringen dass die meisten dieser quellen
gefälscht sind also ein tacitus glaube
ich der hat genau das aufgeschrieben was
das unter dem procurator das ist ein
fehler
es war nämlich ein präfekt pontius
pilatus in seiner zeit ließen die
prokuratur gekreuzigt wurde und helfen
sie mir eben man sagt er noch ist und
dass das nicht erbringt es im kontext
der christenverfolgung der nero nischel
christen verfolgt wurde der autor der
autor dieses ihr glaubens oder wahren
glaubens oder das geschrieben was haben
wir noch wir haben josefus und bei
josephus ist die interessante quelle die
über jakobus den bruder des sogenannten
christus schreibt denn die ist nicht der
fälschung der fälschung oder der
interpolation verdächtig und zeigt dass
josefus auch ein früherer stelle in
seinem geschichtswerk über diesen
sogenannten christus geschrieben hat die
stelle wo das passiert ist in der tat
wahrscheinlich durch künstliche ab
schreiber dann ausgestaltet
und überhöht worden insofern ist es
schwierig darauf zurückzukommen und
haben wir noch eine quelle
wir haben wir haben plinius christen
dass sie christus als ihrem gott gesänge
darbringen bringen
die haben möglicherweise einen syrischen
autor maria was arabien um 70 etwas kurz
nach 70 es sind alles quellen von denen
man nicht beweisen kann dass sie
unabhängig von der christlichen von den
christlichen quellen stehen denn sie
haben alle von jesus wahrscheinlich über
christen gehört jedenfalls kann man
nichts anderes beweisen insofern bei
josefus ist vielleicht der einzige der
es möglicherweise hatte aber da liegt
die ist die quellen situation komplex
trotzdem es gibt zu allen dingen keinen
einzigen es gibt keinen einzigen antiken
autor der bestreitet dass jesus gelebt
überhaupt nichts wissen nein das dass
das bedeutet gar nichts ich möchte nur
eins sagen die quellen situation ist
wesentlich dramatischer als sie die eben
dargestellt haben josef es wird ja
meistens immer so als der hauptzeuge
benutzt sie sprachen jetzt dieses
hollywood - christus an
das war für einen kopisten ein leichtes
ein federstrich ja hier hinzuzufügen der
sogenannte christus man muss ja auch
immer vor augen haben sie meinen das ist
gefällt das ist selbstverständlich wurde
das interpoliert
obwohl doch soviel interpoliert sie
rücken zb doch auch vor dem test in dem
fr die ahnung ab das testimonial saviano
spricht von den weisen menschen jesus
könig der juden spricht ist von den
weisungen von den weisen man gehe von
den weisen könig der juden jesus nicht
das ist jetzt also dieses zeugnis wäre
doch also für frühchristliche für just
een für hippolyt für regen es für
apologeten sehr geeignet gewesen um das
christentum auch publikumswirksam zu
verkaufen
ja hier sagt ein jude wie josephus
spricht hier also von den weisen man
jesus aber diese zeugen also hier ist
ihm die kirchenväter entschuldigung
sprechen gar nicht von dem zeugnis des
josefs sondern dieses zeugnis wird erst
bei seriös im vierten jahrhundert
warum sie das noch nicht
das wollte ich ja jetzt gerade sagen
stichwort und dich wortwechsel balkans
wir haben ja noch nicht über die
sogenannten apokryphen evangelien
gesprochen und die stichhaltigkeit der
quellen über die wir jetzt diskutieren
da fehlt noch ihre position
also wird nicht aus den antiken quellen
da kann ich nur vom märz zustimmungen
ausschließen
mit sicherheit sagen können da hammers
jetzt sondern die haben ihre
informationen über kristen aber ich habe
es für wesentlich dass keiner von denen
auf die idee kommt auch nur den
leisesten zweifel zu haben dass es
diesen jesus gegeben hatten dass sie
unter pontius pilatus hingerichtet
worden ist das finde ich schon mal einen
wichtigen punkt der festzuhalten ist
gegenüber der annahme dass das mythos
wäre und es ist mit überaus sämtliche
todesarten das ist eigentlich nichts
dass
das dass man das erfinden sollte als
christliche gemeinschaft ist ist total
und lausanne gab es ja gibt es ja die
sogenannten apokryphen evangelien wer
war denn da der autor wer waren die
autoren was ist davon zu halten nichts
es handelte sich dabei um christliche
autoren deren schriften sind zum teil
zur selben zeit entstanden wie die
kanonischen schriften also die
evangelien doch als jahres naja hier
oben salomo zum beispiel dass petrus
evangelium wird von manchen autoren
sogar früher datiert als unsere
passionsgeschichte also es sind
christliche autoren die allerdings das
ist natürlich richtig da haben theologen
wie sie dann probleme damit wiederum
einen mythologischen jesus uns
präsentieren und keinen geschichtlichen
einen jesus einen doppischen jesus im
schein la oder zum beispiel ein jesus
wie den roten salons der zunächst
überhaupt gar nicht jesus heißt sondern
nur christus und dessen irdisches
erscheinen sich offenbar auch nur auf
sterben und auferstehen reduziert ich
würde das thomas evangelium gern noch
ins gespräch bringen denn wenn es unter
den apokryphen evangelien eines gibt
dass möglicherweise doch auch
unabhängige traditionen bewahrt hat dann
ist es das und das ist ein evangelium
dass die worte jesu
in einer klassischen redakteure in einer
klassischen erinnerung die sowie die
evangelien durch verschiedene phasen der
erinnerung und der es jeweils update ins
der erinnerungen hindurch gegangen ist
aber da hat man etwas vor sich eine
schrift vorsicht die interessant ist
insofern als sie eine sammlung von
worten jesu ist wie wir sie auch für
eine der quellen der kanonischen
evangelien vermuten können die lobbying
quelle cudi von matthäus und lukas
verwendet worden ist und das ist einer
der gründe warum wir davon ausgehen
können dass die evangelien auch wenn sie
vielleicht etwa nach etwas nach 70 oder
so aufgeschrieben wurden durchaus auch
schriftliche quellen hatten die doch
einige jahrzehnte zwei drei jahrzehnte
noch zurückführen und die loggien quelle
ist dafür eine hypothetische quelle
zugegebenermaßen aber es gibt so viele
wörtliche übereinstimmungen zwischen
matthäus und lukas die aus anderen
gründen doch als unabhängige evangelien
betrachtet werden müssen dass man dies
für im allgemeinen die weitesten
überzeugende theorie hält und dass
thomas evangelium wäre dann eine glace
tisch weiter entwickelte form dieser
selben art eines urchristlichen
evangeliums das nicht am leben jesu
sondern an seiner lehre interessiert war
über die bloße existenz von jesus worten
die bedeutet doch nicht dass es auch
einen historischen jesus gegeben hat wir
wissen doch in den urchristlichen
gemeinden gab es apostel in den
urchristlichen gemeinden gab es eben
aber auch propheten und was ist denn die
aufgabe sicherlich dieser propheten
gewesen diese propheten haben einen
pneumatischen christus verkündet dass
dieser christus ein irdisches wesen
gewesen sein das ist damit ja
schlechthin noch gar nicht gesagt
sondern es ist wohl die sich an jesus
ausgedacht haben der aufgehängt worden
ist an einem römischen kreuz und das dem
in den mund legen nun sie wissen doch
auch das kreuz ist in der geschichte des
christentums vielfältig ausgelegt worden
das ist nicht nur einfach ein schandmal
sondern es ist auch ein sind aktives
innen hohl das bei platon zum beispiel
dem team aus
sehr gehaltvoll auch interpretiert wird
wir lassen die disposition jetzt mal
stehen natürlich wenn sonst nicht
einigen können und wollen aber unsere
zuschauer interessiert doch auch bei der
gelegenheit die zeit in der jesus gelebt
hat oder überliefert wird in welche
politischen und geografischen
verhältnisse wurde er den hineingeboren
visa seine lebenswirklichkeit aus das
ist ein interessanter und auch sehr
umstrittene frage denn er jesus ist
davon kann man doch wohl ausgehen in
galilea aufgewachsen das war zu der zeit
ein römisches klientel fürstentum aber
die römer hatten im gesamten land
eigentlich die oberherrschaft und
gekreuzigt wurde er dann in judäa wo zur
selben zeit ein römischer präfekt die
die leitung hatte da heißt es in einem
spannungsfeld hineingeboren in dem das
land unter römischer besetzung und
machtmissbrauch litt aber die meinung
unter den forschern gehen durchaus
auseinander wie viel davon spürbar war
im galileo des ersten jahrhunderts
ich persönlich habe den eindruck wenn
ich die evangelien diesen optischen
evangelium vor allem lese was da alles
über arme kranke bettler und so weiter
steht das gibt uns schon den eindruck
eines eines landes in dem wirklich die
armen enorm unter druck stehen die
reichen und das sind dann oft auch die
schichten die mit den römern und mit
ihren klientel herrschern
zusammenarbeiten profitieren und reicher
werden und die armen ärmer werden
daraus ergibt sich auch viel von der von
der botschaft jesu wie er sich das reich
gottes vorstellt was das inhaltlich
bedeutet wenn wir das was wir über jesus
wissen oder zu wissen glauben
vergleichen etwa mit dem wissen über die
stifter anderer weltreligion mohammed
oder buddha ist das mehr oder weniger
das weiß ich nicht auf alle fälle weiß
ich dass jesus nicht stifter des
christentums gewesen ist
jesus war ein jude und bezogen auf ihn
hat sich eine jüdische gruppe
gebildet und die menschen die auch nach
seinem tod an ihn als auferstandenen
glaubten haben sich als eine gruppe
innerhalb des judentums verstanden und
das christentum entsteht meiner ansicht
nach erst im zweiten jahrhundert als
immer mehr menschen aus den völkern zu
dieser gruppe hinzu kommen und das
judentum sich nach 70 neu konstituieren
muss und sich nicht mehr sehr viele
unterschiedliche gruppen leisten kann in
deshalb bedrängenden situation nach dem
jüdisch römischen krieg und die sich
dann bildende mehrheit
abweichende gruppen an rand drängt so
dass von diesen beiden seiten her sich
im zweiten jahrhundert dann sozusagen
das christentum bildet und sich sofort
und das halte ich auch für seinen
geburtsfehler als antijüdisch geriert
immer sie liefern im gegensatz zum
judentum versteht und meine intention
wäre in der interpretation der
neutestamentlichen texte ihr jüdisches
profil wieder zu gewinnen und ihren
zusammenhang mit der jüdischen bibel und
dem und im alten testament um damit zu
sagen in der interpretation der not des
mit texte heute ihre antijüdische
wirkungsgeschichte zu beseitigen ich
würde da ganz ganz weit mit ihnen mit
gehen ganz sicher auch was die
entstehung des christentums im zweiten
jahrhundert oder ganz spät im ersten
jahrhundert eigentlich
erst betrifft aber ich frage mich doch
ob nicht die frage nach dem historischen
jesus auch eine gewisse berechtigung hat
in dem zusammenhang dass auch es um die
frage der historisch angemessene
darstellung der gesprächspartner jesu
geht und einer kritischen einer
kritischen hinterfragung der evangelien
in dieser hinsicht und dann frage ich
sie
ob nicht das matthäus-evangelium zum
beispiel schon ein so verzerrtes bild
vom judentum andeutet dass ich natürlich
verstärkt hat dann in der
rezeptionsgeschichte aber ist es nur die
rezeptionsgeschichte des matthäus
evangeliums die antijüdische oder sehen
wir nicht hier bereits einen jesus der
im gegensatz zum judentum gebracht wird
wo er tatsächlich es um immer jüdische
streitpunkte ging jetzt lassen wir
zuerst mal herrn detering dass sie sich
so einig dann möchte ich doch ein
bisschen sand ins getriebe streuen ja
und zwar von nietzsche gibt es ja diesen
schönen spruch dass das christentum und
im judentum
die hebräische bibel das alte testament
unter dem hintern recht gezogen habe und
ich habe das gefühl wenn ich sie beide
so höre dass heute die gegenteilige
tendenz vorherrscht da soll der
christliche jesus durch den jüdischen
jesus theologischer seitz ersetzt werden
und da hätte ich doch nun wirklich große
bedenken denn mit welchem recht machen
sie das eigentlich
es ist auch immer so die sie haben zwar
richtig gesagt die evangelien knüpfen an
das alte testament an in den evangelien
wird jedes als doodle durchaus
dargestellt vollkommen richtig aber auf
der anderen seite ist doch in diesen
evangelien auch eine ganz eindeutige
tendenz zu beobachten sich vom judentum
abzugrenzen
jesus beginnt doch nicht mit der
jüdischen lehrer sondern beginnt mit der
neuen lehre und das erregt daneben auch
das entsetzen seiner umwelt er ist in
einem dauerclinch natürlich in seiner
antrittsrede er ist ein im dauerclinch
mit schriftgelehrten und pharisäer und
er wird schließlich auf geheiß der
jüdischen oberen jedenfalls so die
evangelien gekreuzigt ja also wenn ich
dann vor diesem hintergrund
jesus theologisch im judentum verortet
dann kann ich doch genauso gut martin
luther auch theologisch im katholizismus
verordnet genau das muss man auch tun
eben genau es ist also meiner forschung
übersee habe ich entnommen dass sie
früher auch nach dem historischen jesus
geforscht haben aber dann sind sie davon
abgekommen was ist der hand schuld gab
es da ein come as kurs erlebnis sagen
ich habe in den 70er jahren wo ich so
seit 67 ganz stark politisiert worden
bin
und ja auch von dieser zeit geprägt
wurde habe ich dann in seminaren auch
nach dem historischen jesus gefragt und
dann mit der zeit bis 78 war das erste
mal dann auch eine vorlesung gehalten
über den historischen jesus nun warte
auch ganz stolz drauf und habe natürlich
vorher die texte intensiv untersucht
literat kritisch form geschichtlich
versuch zurück zu gehen nach authenzität
beweisen zu fragen und dann erst
ausgelegt so die folge sind habe ich
dann noch ein zwei drei mal gehalten das
letzte mal anfang 80er jahre in bochum
und ich bekam ein gefühl irgendwas
stimmt da nicht und habe die dann erst
mal liegen gelassen und habe sie mir
dann etliche zeit später noch mal
phasenweise angeguckt unter vielen wir
es wie schuppen von den augen den jesus
den ich nach einer gründlichen
vorbereitung den studierenden dort
vorgetragen hatte
der hatte an der studentenbewegung
teilgenommen hatte aber nicht aber sein
autor und das ist das was sie fuhren mit
dem wechsel bald meinte dieses phänomen
der spiegelung was zuerst schon martin
keller 18 92 seinen grundlegenden
vortrag gesagt hatte es ist der herren
eigner geist in dem jesus sie spiegelt
das lässt sich in der rückschau immer
wunderbaren
beobachten nur wenn man selber gerade
dran ist und denkt man jetzt macht man
es richtig und kann sich den auch nicht
entziehen denn wenn es darum geht was
plausibel ist deutlich zu machen was ist
ein denn plausibel was einem selber am
plausibelsten es muss eigene herz
schlägt und dann projiziert man sich in
den armen jesus rein und das würde ich
lieber sein lassen wollen und es geht
mir um die auslegung der evangelien in
ihrer differenziertheit und dann auch in
der frage der ist sozusagen das innere
jüdischen und er muss man sich klar
machen die sind geschrieben in einer
zeit der auseinandersetzung von
jüdischer minderheit und jüdischer
mehrheit in der zeit zwischen 70 und 100
und diese konflikte die müssen wir bei
der interpretation der evangelien
wahrnehmen und von daher dann auch
aussagen die im kampfgetümmel gemacht
worden sind von der wahl name der
eigenen texte der mehrheits seite wie
sich eine weitere tradition zeigt
relativieren und diese andere seite
genauso ernsthaft hören wie die stimmung
in den evangelien also in seiner jugend
stand fest an ihrer seite
natürlich sind ein produkt von a das hat
sich dann geändert aufgrund eines
erweckungserlebnis vielleicht oder was
resignation der projizieren wir zu viel
in jesus rein
wir projizieren immer da bin ich absolut
einig mit herrn längst nur herr längst
ich glaube dass es überhaupt nicht hilft
zu sagen dann konzentrieren wir uns doch
auf die auslegung der evangelien denn
glauben sie nicht dass ihr nicht auch
hineinprojizieren ihre eigenen
erfahrungen und ihre eigenen wünsche und
ihre eigenen dinge in ihrer auslegung
der evangelien wenn ich an ein text lese
aus einem kommentar über ein evangelium
dann kann ich wenn ich ein bisschen den
autor kenne schon eine vermutung haben
das ist von längst und das ist von
bultmann und das heißt wir entkommen dem
problem doch nicht indem wir die frage
nach dem historischen jesus sein lasse
aber es gibt einen entscheidenden
unterschied wenn ich die evangelien
auslege dann habe ich für alle kleinen
für alle selben text als grundlast auch
nicht bei der historische jesus rufe
bastelt sich doch jede und jeder
eben eine grundlage zurück das ist nicht
wahr denn die evangelien das wissen wir
und da können auch sie nicht von
abstrahieren haben eine tiefendimension
wir wissen dass da verschiedene lagen
drin sind das da traditionen aufgenommen
sind
jeder jeder nimmt das mit in seiner
auslegung und darum würde ich sagen die
die verschiedenen bilder des
historischen jesus die stehen in unserer
zeit neben den verschiedenen jesus
bildern die aus den evangelien
herausgelesen werden und auch das sind
immer selektive und subjektive rees
weisen der evangelischen menschen können
nicht anders wenn sie texte lesen und
sich mit historischen phänomenen
beschäftigen als auch ihre eigene
position dabei mit ins spiel bringen
ich denke dass es im grundprinzip nicht
anders ist und dass und dann kommt für
mich die rechtfertigung doch der
historischen jesus forschung dass wir
als personen der auch der aufklärung der
neuzeit einfach nicht anders können ich
jedenfalls kann nicht anders als mich
wenn ich solche geschichten lesen zu
fragen und wo hat das jetzt ein anhalt
an einer historischen gestalt und wo
hinter allerlei spätere reflexion
ich wollte aufgenähte ring alten
profitiert die kirche denn davon wir
müssen so ganz allmählich zum ende kommt
profitiert die kirche eigentlich davon
dass die quellenlage so überschaubar ist
und fest ich gerade das vielleicht den
glauben der gläubigen provokant gefragt
inwiefern da habe ich jetzt ihre frage
vielleicht nicht ganz verstanden sollte
die kirche jetzt davon profitieren von
der klaren quellenlage oder von der
unklaren formularen quellen leide
das ist durchaus möglich das ist
durchaus möglich dass glaube ich auch
aber ich wollte jetzt noch einmal ganz
kurz zu dem west frau märz im sagt er
etwas ergänzen und dann möchte ich mich
dann doch noch mal auf die seite auch
hier von herrn
längst schlagen fällt ihnen das denn
nicht selber auf das der jesus in ihrem
historischen jesus als emanzipatorische
als frauenfreundlicher als familien
kritischer als kritischer frauen
ökonomie kritischer wahrscheinlich auch
als ökologischer jesus das weiß ich
nicht
dass der nicht dass der ausdruck des
zeitgeistes hier unserer bundesrepublik
in den 80er und 90er jahren ist jede
zeit stellt ihre fragen und jederzeit
stellt indem sie ihre fragen stellt auch
berechtigte fragen an die quellen würde
ich sagen
in unseren evangelischen in der tat kaum
was über frauen trotzdem was auch damals
so dass 50 prozent der bevölkerung
frauen waren dass jesus in seinen
interaktionen mit frauen zu tun hatte
und dass wir nur aufgrund der
patriarchalen darstellung der quellen
nur sehr wenig darüber wissen wenn wir
jetzt geschärft durch eine bestimmte
historische situation neu nach den
quellen schauen und dann mehr sehen als
man bisher gesehen hat dann ist das
nicht nur projektionen da ist immer auch
projektion aber über die verschiedenen
phasen der projektion
wer wird auch fortschritt in der
historischen erkenntnis meiner meinung
nach erreicht das geht in mini schritten
es ist auch oft quellen wenig da bin ich
es bin ich bin ich mit ihnen eins aber
es ist kein zufall dass inzwischen
selbst die konservativsten
fundamentalistischen autoren versuchen
zu integrieren was angestoßen durch die
feministische bewegung über jesus und
die frauen herausgefunden ist und
irgendwo auf dem mittelfeld des
historisch plausiblen hat sich auf dem
feld unsere kenntnis doch erweitert
würde ich sagen nicht reicht da was in
den evangelien finde ihre schichten
argument sie irgendeine aussage dass den
evangelien der für alle gleiche text
wenigstens vorliegt überzeugt mich
überhaupt nicht natürlich sind die
evangelien nicht
einem guss geschrieben worden sondern
haben unterschiedliche traditionen
verarbeitet aber muss doch beim
literarischen text davon ausgehen dass
der letzte verantwortliche autor das was
er als gesamtes dann hinstellt auch als
ein gesamtwerk versteht und als ganzes
ernst genommen werden muss das ist der
eine punkt warum ich das wichtiger finde
nicht nach ist durch nächste frage von
evangelium zu nehmen und der andere
punkt ist deren wenn wir mit der aus
mitteln der deutung wenn sie nach dem
historischen jesus fragen nach dem
historischen geschehen dann haben sie
die frage was kommt denn dem tatsächlich
geschehenen was eben auch nur immer eins
gewesen sein am nächsten
wenn ich aber die evangelien auslege
habe ich einen literarischen text der
ein auslegungs potenzial enthält was
nicht nur eine auslegung nämlich meine
erlaubt sondern viele auslegungen und
dann ist die frage von möglichen und
unmöglichen auslegungen nämlich
vieldeutig vielfältigkeit ohne
beliebigkeit ziehen wie am ende am ende
jetzt ein kurzes fazit frommherz stellen
wir uns mal vor und die frage geht an
sie alle ein zehnjähriges mädchen fazit
wer jesus was er wieder in sivas
einsehen es war ein jüdischer
wundertäter der den menschen gott nahe
brachte der eine vision hatte von einer
gerechten welt
er hoffte und dachte dass sie bald
einbrechen hereinbrechen würde das ist
so nicht geschehen
aber das erstaunliche ist obwohl er
gekreuzigt wurde und in einen
schrecklichen tod starb haben seine
freundinnen und freunde die seine
botschaft miterlebt haben die erfahrung
gemacht erlebt so eine sache geht weiter
hat ein durchaus nahe stehender theologe
mal gesagt haben
geschichten über ihn erzählt und das
können wir nachlesen in den evangelien
erledigt was sagen sie einem
zehnjährigen mädchen
ich würde sagen ich weiß nicht ob die
geschichten die wir über jesus aus der
bibel lesen
historisch sind ob sie wirklich passiert
sind oder ob sie nur eine art märchen
sind
ich glaube den begriff märchen wird ein
zehnjähriger sicherlich verstehen
aber wie dem auch sei es ist ganz
gleichgültig diese geschichten haben uns
etwas zu sagen
es sind sinnbilder sind symbole die uns
heute betreffen und die uns auch in
unserem glauben in unserem christlichen
glauben weiterhelfen
er wächst was sagen sie ich kann mich
weitgehend frau märz anschließen was ich
konkret mache wird sich beim
heranwachsen meiner enkel zeigen
ich möchte aber an das letzte noch mal
anknüpfen eine liegengelassene frage
noch einmal aufnehmen
die mir ganz ganz wichtig ist nämlich
was daran liegt dass ist die sich die
erzählungen der evangelien auf einen
bestimmten menschen beziehen wie sich
die geschichte jüdischen bibel auf die
geschichte des volkes israel bezieht das
nämlich hier bot und partikulare
geschichte zusammengedacht werden und
damit zu sagen gott in die geschichte
gezogen wird und nicht wie bei den
philosophen das höchste vollkommene ist
was dann ab hts ich würde mal sagen
apathisch ist der biblisch bezeugte gott
ist nicht apathisch der ist dem tiefsten
sinn des wortes sympathisch sich nämlich
mit leidend und er lässt sich in
mitleidenschaft ziehen
und daran nicht mehr alles wie schön
dass man über jesus reden und auch
streiten kann
ich glaube dass man das in anderen
religionen nicht so offen machen kann
frau merz meine herren ich danke ihnen
sehr für ihre interessanten
diskussionsbeiträge ich habe was gelernt
und in liebe zuschauer danke ich für
interesse bleiben sie uns treu